pikmin it's not as recognizable as mario
or zelda but it's certainly one of
nintendo's most
unique franchises you grow and manage
little vegetable creature dudes who age
you in battle
help you solve puzzles and collect name
brand items and
nintendo's rendition of a real-time
strategy set and honey i shrunk the kids
and i can't
get enough of it so with the
announcement of pikmin 3 deluxe on
nintendo switch we said hey
let's take a look back at the history of
[Music]
pikmin
like many of nintendo's most beloved
games the mastermind behind pikmin was
shigeru miyamoto in an interview with
the telegraph
miyamoto recounts as he was getting
older he started to grow an interest
in gardening and when he saw a line of
ants marching past his feet and
into the grass carrying leaves he
imagined what it might look like if they
were
tiny people he said quote when we think
about video games we always have the
idea of a start
and a goal and it's like a race between
individual players
who can make it and who won't and i
thought why does it have to be a
competition
why can't everyone just move together in
the same direction carrying things
as a team who made the rules in the
first place anyway you
tell him miyamoto now the idea for
pikmin wasn't perfected from the start
originally he had an idea for a game
called adam and
eve where two humans developed life and
you as the player is the god-like
character
now your actions could help them love or
make them
fight but either way there was potential
for them to
have children and populate an entire
planet which kind of sounds like
miyamoto's the sense basically moving
sweet
i would have played that ultimately the
idea was deemed too
uninteractive so it was shelved but the
one thing nintendo really wanted to push
was how the new gamecube hardware could
produce 100 plus
ai on the screen at a time at space
world 2000
nintendo showed off a tech demo for what
was known
as super mario 128. in it 128 mario
characters
were all simultaneously on screen
carrying objects around
super mario 128 never materialized but
the tech
was definitely used for pikmin the
original pikmin came out close to the
launch of the nintendo gamecube
in 2001 in it you play as captain omar
whose ship is hit by a meteor causing
him to crash land on an unknown
planet that happens to look a whole lot
like earth
with his ship in utter disarray and only
30 days to restore it before his support
runs out
he must partner up with the strange
walking plant creatures that inhabit the
planet
they're unquestionably loyal to the
point that they'll sacrifice themselves
to fight
monstrous insects collect treasure and
generally do
all of olimar's bidding each color
pikmin has its own strengths
red are strong and fire resistant yellow
or light and can be thrown further
in blue can swim pikmin ultimately did
pretty well both critically and
commercially so
a new pikmin game was put into
development in fact it was confirmed in
the december 2002
issue of japan's weekly playboy magazine
by miyamoto himself
that's right they had a game section
alongside very well written articles too
pikmin 2 was released two years later in
2004
and built on the core formula by adding
tons of new additions
the story takes place immediately after
pikmin 1 which is a rare occurrence in
nintendo games as they usually don't
carry on narratives between
sequels olomar makes it back to his home
planet of hokotate
only to find out that the company he
works for hoco tate freight
is in massive debt because louis a
fellow employee of the company
lost a major shipment of golden picnic
carrots to a
space bunny did you get all that
turns out the souvenir omar brought back
for his son is worth more than a year's
salary on hoko tate
so the president of the company
instructs omar and louis to head back to
the planet omar was
just stranded on to collect enough
treasure to pay off their 10
000 poco's debt dude didn't even get to
say hello to his wife and kids
it's messed up so now there are two
characters you can control in pikmin 2
olemar
and louis and this added some complexity
to the management gameplay of the game
omar can have a group over on one side
doing something while louis has another
and you can swap between them with the
tab of a button
a couple of other new additions are the
no day limit and
a new cave system with multiple sub
floors where time
stops but you can only use the pikmin
you took with you
there are also new pikmin added purple
pikmin who are strong but heavy and slow
and white pikmin who are immune to
poison and can dig up buried treasure
but are weak
in battle nintendo also added a
two-player mode in a challenge mode
where you
joined by a specific number of pikmin
collect as much treasure as you can
within the time limit
pikmin 2 was well received with many
president first new additions
and the removal of the d limit it was
another hit
for nintendo a sequel seemed imminent
but
instead pikmin took a long slumber
pikmin 3 went through a variety of
iterations before becoming
what it is today at first a pikmin game
was being made for nintendo's handheld
like the game boy advance but miyamoto
deemed the hardware too weak
for a pikmin game development then
shifted to the wii this was first hinted
at in 2007 during an interview with ign
shakira miyamoto told the site quote i
certainly don't think we've seen the
last of pikmin i definitely would like
to do something with them and i think
the wii interface in particular
is very well suited to that franchise in
2009 however nintendo released the
new play control series which was
basically adding wii remote support to
gamecube games and the first two pikmin
games were part of that lineup
oddly enough pikmin 2 was released with
all the other games in
every region except for north america
where it was held
until 2012. anyways
some tiny gameplay and graphical tweaks
were made but the biggest thing was that
you could use motion controls to play
the game
that's allowed you to be more precise
with your aim and even move the cursor
further
these ports were also released on the
wii u e shot meaning technically
you could play pikmin 1 and 2 in hd
right now if you have a wii u going back
to pikmin 3
not much else was heard from the game
other than the confirmation of its
existence in 2008 but at e3 2011
it was revealed that pikmin 3 would be
coming to nintendo's next home console
the wii u miyamoto stated that the hd
visuals
and gamepad were better complement to
the series which
is why it moved pikmin 3 also continues
the story
started in the first two games which
again is uncommon for a nintendo
franchise but given that this title was
released
9 years after pikmin 2 nintendo changed
it up enough for newcomers to understand
what's going on
just like the title implies pikmin 3 had
three protagonists
elf britney and charlie and they're all
from the planet koppai
due to a booming population and lack of
planning copai is left with a major food
shortage
so they send scout vessels to look for
resources on other planets
and while the situation seems dire the
crew manages to find food on what they
dub
pnf-4 the now official name of the
planet from
all three pikmin games unfortunately for
them their ship the ss drake
crashed lands and the three need to
reunite if only there were native
creatures to the area
willing to help them pikmin 3 like
pikmin 2 is similar to its predecessor
at its core but adds a ton of new things
while changing
others the game's day limit is now based
on how much fruit you collect
as you need to consume it at the end of
every day run out of fruit and
you're dead pikmin now hit specific body
parts so
certain enemies were given weak spots
enemies retain their damage taken
overnight so if you don't finish a
battle before the day ends
it's no biggie and now all the pikmin
onions are merged into one versus the
three onions from previous games
the game also features a two-player
bingo battle and a mission mode where
you finish specific challenges
like collecting treasures or defeating
enemies within a time limit
mission mode also received paid dlc in
the form of remixed and new missions
purple and white pikmin were removed
from the main game and instead
we were introduced to two new pigmen
rock the best
chunker boys in town and winged rock
pikmin
literally look like rocks and are strong
in battle while also being able to break
glass and crystal
wayne pikmin are weak in battle but can
fly pull things out of the ground and
avoid all elemental hazards on the
ground purple and white pikmin could be
found in the game's other modes bingo
battle and mission mode
the game also had a handful of control
schemes to accommodate nintendo's
various controllers
like the wii u gamepad the wii u pro
controller and the wii remote and
nunchuck but
no matter what you chose you still
needed the gamepad as the map and
inventory
pikmin 3 like its predecessors was
received well critically and
sold well the for the wii u
shortly before the launch of pikmin 3
miyamoto announced that he was working
on a pikmin cartoon
miyamoto said the idea of these cartoons
came when he was trying to give more
life to the pikmin characters while it
didn't make its target 2013 air date
three original pikmin short movies
were screened at the tokyo international
film festival in october 2014
before making their way to the 3ds and
wii u eshops a month later
now i remember earlier when i said
miyamoto deemed the handheld hardware
too weak for pikmin
well as it turned out nintendo made a
handheld one anyways but except it
wasn't
really like pikmin like a little it has
pigment but it's not
it's not like the others in 2017 hey
pikmin a 2.5 d
puzzle platformer was released for the
nintendo 3ds not much is publicly known
about the development of the game but
it was the first pikmin game not
developed internally
by nintendo instead being handled by a
company named arzest which
also did the 3ds versions of mario and
sonic at the rio 2016
olympic games and poochie and yoshi's
woolly world
this game's story is separate from the
others with omar yet again
crash landing on an unknown planet
except this time
the ship just needs fuel instead of
pieces so it's up to olimar and the
pikmin to collect 30 000 sparkling
so he can return home oh listen doc i
tore a hole in the gas tank when i was
landing so we're gonna have to patch it
up and get some gas
you mean we're out of gas yeah it's no
big deal
the game is linear and you mostly moved
right and instead of growing and
managing pikmin
you only use the pikmin you find in each
level the game had no day system
allowing you to take as long as you need
and throwing the pikmin was done by
using touch controls
omar was a little more versatile in this
game thanks to a jet pack
and the ability to swim but pikmin were
still the ones doing all the leg work
the game released with a pikmin amiibo
figure and amiibo functionality
that allowed you to scan in characters
like mario and the inklings as treasure
you can collect for sparklium and even
read olomar's thoughts about them in
japanese olomar
is an anagram for mario so they have a
stronger bond
than you might think the game was met
with mixed reception due to its
simplistic gameplay and you know
not being a fully fledged pikmin game it
didn't help that the game was released
in summer 2017
right after the nintendo switch had come
out and that's the last of pikmin
until now start in august 2020
nintendo revealed that pikmin 3 deluxe
would be heading to the nintendo switch
on october 30th 2020. on top of
everything mentioned about pikmin 3 this
new deluxe version allows you to play
the entire game
co-op has new difficulty modes includes
all the dlc from the original game
introduces a new prequel
and epilogue starring olimar and louie
and brings in the piclopedia which like
an encyclopedia gives you the rundown on
creatures and plants you've discovered
in game
as well as thoughts from the crew
members about them you could even unlock
in-game
badges achievements from meeting certain
conditions like log 10 piklopedia
entries
and that's about it for the main pikmin
games captain olimar and the pikmin have
appeared in super smash bros brawl
3ds wii u and ultimate as a playable
character
and had a role in brawl's story mode in
smash 3ds
wii u and ultimate elf is an alternate
costume for omar and olmar got his own
smash amiibo figure there's also a
pikmin minigame that was included in
nintendo land the mini game launch title
for the wii u
on top of that pikmin make a fun little
appearance when you transfer data from a
dsi
to a 3ds or a wii to a wii u in terms of
the future of this series well
we know but we don't know on september
17th of 2015
yes five years ago miyamoto told in that
playboy but eurogamer that pikmin 4 was
very close to completion he also said we
can confirm that pikmin 4 is in
development but that is all we can
confirm
at the present at e3 2017 miyamoto
confirmed again
to your gamer that pikmin 4 is still
progressing but
that's the last we heard from it maybe
it's still in development maybe it's
been scrapped
maybe the pikmin 3 deluxe sales will
help nintendo gage interest
who really knows anyways thanks for
joining us on this
expedition through the history of pikmin
let me know in the comments why your
favorite pikmin is the rock pikmin tell
me in a
haiku or a poem tell me just tell me why
the rock one is the best one because it
is the best one
for everything pikmin related keep it
here that game spot
see you later
[Music]
how good these are look how good
look how good my pikmin are yeah
[Music]
okay